in this class there was one guy who was
always talking he would raise his hand
first thing for every single question he
had a big opinion on all these topics
i'm like dude how does this guy know
about all this stuff
and he was just super into the internet
and
um at the time my head labeled this guy
as a loser i was like wow this guy's
like this over eager student
who's like kind of a know-it-all and
like kind of sucking up to the teacher
and like why is he so into this
wow what what a loser he spends his
nights of researching the like pros and
cons of naturality
okay now fast forward now that's me i'm
that loser i was just late to the game
and that guy dan ended up joining
coinbase as one of the early employees
i feel like i could rule the world i
know i could be
what i want to i put my all in it like
no days off
on the road let's travel never looking
back what is your
rating of today's episode uh i'd go a
minus
um we rambled a lot but i kind of like
that that we go into different topics
i mean we're everywhere pod group hacker
new stuff
crypto for hacker news the origin
stories of product hunt
75 hard tony horton sean pouring his
heart out at the end
we got everything in there what was your
top two favorite things
um i like talking about like the origin
story so uh
product hunt how ryan kind of hacked his
way to growing that that was kind of
cool
um the p90x origin story as well that
was kind of cool i have to look up that
youtube video that sean mentioned
that was definitely interesting
listeners let us know if you like having
this up front
um let's get to the today's podcast
all right what's up what's up sorry i
was late i was uh
sitting here working podcast bro nobody
knows you were late
um i'm never the late one i take pride
in that
and i uh was just literally sitting here
working and i
had no idea i didn't even look at them
the funny thing is i was also two
minutes late but um
when i saw your message that was like uh
hey sorry i'm running that i'll be there
in a minute i was like
boom hop i need to hop in there now so
i'm there first
i'm not typically the late one but i was
but i will tell you a few things that i
was working on so
just a quick recap i'm working on some
growth stuff so i want to run
just a few quick ideas by you this will
take a second but first yeah
so in the last whenever we launched
however long that's been
not including month one to month two
because it was like a 500 percentage
growth rate so i'm not including that we
have grown
on average 10 a month okay
okay this month uh
april's not over but if if you take the
average of the trail in three weeks and
give it a fourth week it's going to be
about 400
a little bit over 400 000 downloads
which
um if you so if you take that multiplied
by then uh to january
so we're going to hit a million
downloads a month by around january
at ten percent growth rate if we keep
going at this rate
yeah um so right now we're on pace for
about five million downloads a year and
then
what you're saying well it's it's more
hundred thousand downloads a month
that's five million a year
that's a that's assuming zero growth
right right with the with the growth
it'll be like six million or something
like that more
seven eight ish okay yeah because the
last the end of the year is going to be
starting to get 800
900 a million downloads a month and dude
if people start commuting
they need a little they need a little
good good good in their ears while
they're commuting that's what we needed
we took a
20 cut i think when cove happened yeah i
saw the numbers dip and then we rebuilt
from there
so the the current growth rate is
actually quite good it's just like it's
just
this is the same thing of like if you
just focus and just do the same old same
old over and over and over again it's
gonna work
but of course we wanna expedite that and
so the things that
we're working on is we've already talked
about what we worked on but let me bring
up a few things first
i actually think that we need to be a
little bit tighter with our content
meaning
we're like i don't watch sports but i
know you do what are like the sports
shows where they like go through topic
by topic and they like
you have like a time limit yeah like
pardon the interruption they do that
where it's like five minutes it's like
all right we're talking about and they
always have like
you know the [__] people care about or
you know they have these these little
like names on the side and it's like you
kind of want to tune in to hear what
they're going to say about x and what
are they going to say about why
so um i think we should start doing that
and i'm trying to figure out how to do
it but
uh i i would like us to we're going to
start i'm going to try it for an episode
and i'll coordinate it next everything
that is on instagram and on youtube we
have to drive
all traffic to itunes not to spotify
even though a lot of people say they
listen to spotify the numbers are more
people just barely though listen to
itunes
but if you click subscribe on itunes it
automatically downloads and we get
credit for that whereas spotify
it doesn't do that so gaming the the
system and playing within the rules
that's the way to go and we currently
are not linking to any of our itunes
stuff
finally um or no the second to last
thing is
recapping old stuff so we have 170
episodes did you know that
i didn't know that it's a that's a lot
yeah um and so what i'm gonna do is go
through all the old ones and bucket them
into categories and we could re-release
them just with the new intro because
right um i think uh they'll be great
dude that's that's really smart if we
basically take our best episodes from
earlier when we had half the size of the
audience
and maybe we cut off some [__] if it
was like there was something dumb but we
just take the
you know in the mo like last year this
month if we had three good episodes and
we just say
boom we're bringing back those business
ideas and re
repackaging them in a way that's better
and we sort of re-release our greatest
hits
uh i think that's a good idea what i
would think is the fact
i think that will work but what i was
thinking of is
grouping it so uh let's say that in
episode
5 and then 34 and then and eight
we there was a religion based thing like
a church like
make a religion the new composition yeah
yeah so you do that
and the reason why is so you can create
a how-to title because what i've looked
at all the data
anything that's how-to related gets more
than pass
uh more than other stuff speaking of
which smart and this is the one of the
last things
we can re-title old ones to be more
click
i'll [__] say it click bait headlines
um
and then last but not least alex garcia
on my team who's been going wild on
twitter is gonna join uh the podcast
team a little bit as
growth uh and then we also
are hooking up with hubspots uh they've
got a team that
or an outsourced production company that
i want to look into
uh and they have claimed that if you get
a lot of
like if you increase the production
value significantly even on [__] like
this it increases downloads
i don't believe it but it's interesting
right
well we're going to throw it all at the
wall and we're going to see what happens
um
speaking of growth can i transition to
an
app that's growing that i want to talk
about or or we can actually
we can do your rundown of the things
we're going to talk about on this
episode so
i'm going to talk about some things that
are in the fitness space so
um this app 75 hard and how it relates
to p90x and a whole bunch of different
fitness things
trends that i've seen so i'm going to
break that down in detail
we're going to talk about um hacker news
and basically
niche news websites and you have an
opinion on that and said why
and then we might talk about mvnos i'm
not sure if i'll get to it today did you
have any other ones that you wanted to
talk about
and what was your last one nbnos this is
when you basically can start your own
cell phone carrier company
uh it's pretty cool uh there's much
stuff i think that that that actually
probably might be a lead
for i think next one because that's a
pretty big idea i think it's really
interesting and i
and i and i what i did this week is i
actually just researched everything you
had and i have points and counter points
and i didn't research that one because
it's very interesting can we wait for
the next one
it takes a lot yeah right and instead go
to uh
this teachable for devs thing because i
have some intel for that so i went and
got
some intel on that i went and got intel
on uh 75 hard
and i think the most interesting is the
hacker new stuff i uh
i went and talked to a friend andrew
your friend our friend who owns uh
a company in the space and they got all
his uh numbers
okay great all right where do you want
to start we can start on any of those
topics hacker news
okay so so i was looking at i saw this
tweet
from this guy dan romero and um
dan romero actually it's kind of a funny
story i'll just leave in with a personal
story so
when i was in college i don't know when
you were in college were you trying
like what was your strategy were you
trying to take the hard classes the easy
classes
what you're interested in yeah so so if
you could take so some people do the
hard ones some people do what they're
most interested in and some people like
me we're just looking for the easy way
out yeah
and it sounds like you're the same and
so i need to uh rate my professor
i use rate my professor and i'll find
the easiest classes um i would find out
what classes the football players and
the basketball players got to take
because uh those are the easy classes so
like rocks for jocks was the code name
for this
uh class i was like geology but it was
like the easiest [__] class ever
i got into this class rock i don't know
how i was
genuinely trying to take a uh like a
interesting class about sports sports
psychology sports medicine or something
like that
and it turns out this was a class only
the female basketball players at duke
were in
so there was 10 students they were all
the female basketball players at duke
the class never i looked at the schedule
like oh there's no classroom where does
this where do i go where do i go for my
class
i email the teacher he's like there's no
physical meetings for this course i
don't know how you got all this
but he's like you just need to read this
one book it was the lance armstrong book
um liv whatever his book was called and
at the end of the year so bring that one
book which is like the easiest [__]
book to read by the way
and then at the end of the year you
write a two-page report on it and that
was the whole class no you're so like
sorry duke you know you definitely do
the thing that all schools do with
education
i i get that why it's cool when you're a
kid but also as a kid and now as an
adult who's gonna send his kids to
college i'm like
what a waste waste of money what yeah
dude
i thought i hadn't hit the lottery i was
like one athlete in college and they
made me take
i was a runner mind you they made me
take gym
and the gym class was aerobic walking
it's like if you got to the classroom
you're done you show up and then you go
for a walk
that it was called a robot and i was
like an athlete
so okay so anyway so in that process one
class that i took that i was just trying
to find an easy class was called like
the internet or something like that i
was like oh bingo i know about that one
let me give that one
and at this time i'm not thinking like
i'm not who i am today right i don't i
wasn't thinking about business
i didn't think i was gonna go into the
tech space i thought i was going to be a
doctor i was a pretty i was very average
student like b minus student
uh very lazy and that's who i was and so
i go to this class and in this class i'm
basically just there again because i'm
trying to coast to an a
in some easy class that's called the
internet it can't be that hard and it
really wasn't that hard it was a
discussion about like internet topics
like net neutrality and stuff like that
and i didn't really give a [__]
i just sat there quietly like doing the
crossword puzzle in the like school
newspaper
eating chick-fil-a in this like
classroom hoping the professor never
calls on me
but in this class there was one guy who
was always talking he would raise his
hand
first thing for every single question he
had a big opinion on all these topics
i'm like dude how's this guy know about
all this stuff
and he was just super into the internet
and
um at the time my head labeled this guy
as a loser i was like wow this guy's
like this over eager student
who's like kind of a know-it-all and
like kind of sucking up to the teacher
and like why is he so into this
wow what what a loser he spends his
nights of researching the like pros and
cons of net neutrality
okay now fast forward now that's me i'm
that loser i was just late to the game
and that guy dan ended up joining
coinbase as one of the early employees
and he basically helped brian armstrong
the ceo of coinbase was kind of like did
this tweet storm the day they went
public right they go public at 100
billion
evaluation and he's like talking about
the journey he's like
when we started this you know it was
such humble beginnings nobody knew about
the space blah blah
he's telling and then this happened and
then dan romero
came on board and like helped break us
into europe and that was a pivotal
moment for the company where we became
like the only crypto company that was
like partnered with banks in europe
and i was like oh my god it's that
[__] guy from my classroom like oh
holy [__] he made it and uh you know i
bet this guy
you know banked tens of millions if not
a hundred million dollars plus
easily just on coinbase and if he owned
any bitcoin along the way which
of course he did because he he joined in
2014 and if you're a believer at that
time you probably
grabbed some so anyways that's my short
story of like wow
if you're a college student listening to
this now just be the nerd now trust me
you're going to want to be that nerd
later and
uh really think through what are you
what are you optimizing for like
ease or like learning something like
doing something interesting
for people i think we have to send this
podcast to dan i think you should
apologize
i i will issue he doesn't even probably
know who i was because again i was this
[__] silent guy eating chick-fil-a in
the back of the class never said a word
i was just judging him in my head and i
i do apologize to dan
for judging him uh and clearly i was
wrong and
he's done amazing so anyway he he put
out a tweet
i follow him and he was like why isn't
there a hacker news
so if you don't know hacker news there's
this website that people just post links
it's like reddit but it's just for
engineers
reddit but only one forum
and well it's not a form it's like you
post links and it's all
nerd culture internet your startup
culture
we you know back in the day we used to
get the newspaper every day and open it
up
and like my dad would go to the business
of politics section i would go to the
sports section
well the internet just made it so that
there's an infinite number of sections
and so now
if you're an engineer you would wake up
and you would maybe go to hacker
hacker news every single day same and um
so anyways it's cool website it's you
know started by paul graham
and it's sort of baked into y combinator
um i i've
i've done an exercise by the way i'm
trying to like what would you value
hacker news at
um and i think it's sort of priceless i
pretty much think there's no price where
paul would sell hacker dudes um no
because he's probably a billionaire and
he loves it but if you were just like a
normal guy and you had a valued off
revenues i think it would be worth 50 to
100 million dollars i bet you it can
make 8 million
a year in revenue with no employees and
i bet you it's
been capable of doing that for about 10
years yeah i would say easily 100
million dollars
because it's also the category leader
it's the end of one in its category
anyway so
um dan tweeted this out he goes why
isn't there a hacker news for
crypto you know like any like discussion
for all the interesting things that are
happening besides the price
which i think is like the key
distinction here um which is that almost
all the conversation there's a lot of
places that talk about crypto and
they're almost all just tracking the
daily price moves like over the weekend
crypto went down like 17 and so
everybody was like
talking about the price and in reality
there's a whole lot of other interesting
developments technologies kind of like
usage um
that's happening that's not price
related and you almost need a firewall
to say look at in this forum you don't
talk about price because otherwise price
is always going to dominate the
conversation
uh that's just the nature of crypto and
so i thought that was kind of
interesting i started looking into some
of these
and i guess like for me i would say like
there is an opportunity
for somebody to create the hacker news
of crypto and so i i'll throw out a
couple that were pretty cool that i
found
one is casebitcoin.com and this is
basically a website that's just
it's just a dashboard of stats so it's
not like news and links it's just
dashboard of stats
that's basically saying um this is the
case for bitcoin
it's like bitcoin is now work you know
10 of gold market cap
here's new here's the top headlines
about pro bitcoin is this a pro bitcoin
dashboard remember that time
that you made bitcoin headlines because
you tweeted that you're putting 20
of your net worth into bitcoin and
someone wrote like
entrepreneur and investor sean perry and
then you didn't
i don't think you did put twenty percent
of your network no i did i did i
i tweeted i was putting 25 i ended up
putting 20
and then it grew the price started going
up so fast
that that quickly became it's now like
almost 50 of my net worth or something
so
it's you know it ended up being more but
but it was ridiculous that there was
news about it because i think they
thought
i was much wealthier than i am uh like
i'm not going to move the needle
it crypto i could put 100 of my net
worth in it it was not gonna move the
needle of crypto crypt was too big
and so that was funny my actually my
college friends texted that news article
to me
this week and they're like whoa what
what is this by the way
what have you become yeah and that was
like before you actually got famous fame
i mean you're like kind of a big deal
now and that was like pre big deal
well that's part of the strategy of
becoming a big deal was uh
carry yourself like you're a big deal
right me announcing how i'm
moving my net worth around is sort of
like carrying yourself like you're a big
deal
even before you are and people start to
like they just accepted my
my implication that i'm a big deal for
tweeting like i was gonna like
calling like my car my furniture assets
and just start using words like that
[Laughter]
so i was looking at some of these
websites cryptopanic.com is a cool one
um anyway so there's some of these
nothing i would say has has broken
through as like
the place where people who care about
this long term and are not they don't
want to
get caught in the price roller coaster
day to day where they go all right so
i'm gonna pause there that's just the
idea
hey i think somebody can create this i
think maybe pomp or somebody who's like
a central figurehead in crypto similar
to paul graham
maybe pop should be creating the hacker
news for crypto that is
specifically not about price um i i
think that would be a smart move if i
was pumped i would consider doing that
uh but you had some thoughts on these
types of businesses and i think that's
where more value will come so
so go into yeah so let's call these
aggregators i guess because you're not
actually creating anything but you're
aggregating
and in a the hustle is like a a
is a little bit of an aggregator we we
create stuff but we aggregate a lot
um so i know a little bit about
aggregating aggregator businesses and i
think that they're really really great
if you can have them if you can make
them uh i was with ryan uh what's his
name
ryan hoover the day before he was
launching product hunt which is
ultimately
kind of like an aggregator and he
totally and he was telling me about it
and i go
oh this is really dumb this is not gonna
work uh
i was wrong it worked out wonderfully he
did a really good job um
financially it was mildly successful but
it was
culturally incredibly successful and
could have been even more successful we
owned it for a long time but anyway
um now i went and talked to andrew
wilkinson who's going to be on the
podcast actually tomorrow
which i don't know for the people
listening when that actually airs
tomorrow the next day something like
that
he bought this thing called web designer
news so it's actually just web design i
think it's just
designer news oh just is it justice that
are you sure i think it's just designer
news.com yeah
i'm pretty sure it is um let's see oh
yeah sorry not web designer
uh designer news okay so basically this
was a
hacker news thing um it was just for
designers
it's like it was literally a clone like
it looked almost the same except for
then hacking is kind of ugly they just
clean up the design a little bit but
it's the same idea
yeah and it was pretty uh pretty good
when he bought it
uh and i asked him how's it going and he
said it's basically dead
uh it's done so uh i think he got the
money back from what he paid for it as
in he earned that much
back but he i don't think he anticipates
making a lot more money
and what i thought was his case his
opinion and what happened my opinion of
what happened to his site is actually
kind of the same but basically
uh here's what he told me he goes the
issue is you have to get a whole bunch
of people to visit daily and you're only
as good as your posters because it's
social news
and there's endless amounts a way to
game the system with a bunch of bots
which
oddly people do it a lot so you need
constant moderation and algorithms which
is very expensive to hire the devs to
make that and then you also need real
live moderators which also is expensive
and then if you have any period where
the content gets bad then everyone just
moves to red
reddit so it's a little bit like
lightning in the bottle and it has this
kind of magical network effect but it's
hard to catch lightning in a bottle is
what he said
and uh i actually agree with that and so
my point is i actually think that
if you can build this it is one of the
greatest things that you can own
um and there's a few examples of this so
there's tech meme which is also
these are all uh things i'm fan of so
it's all gonna be a little bit but tech
meme
i i can't submit to it as a user right
it's not social news they
they curate it themselves well it solves
the same problem
yeah it solves the same problem for the
end customer which is you go to a place
and you see all the interesting links of
the day
in my niche that i can the same habit
and the reason why it's
that it's important to mention tech me
because with hacker news as with reddit
uh the creators or the owners of the
site can actually just submit a ton of
fake stuff that you wouldn't even know
they submitted and it would look
populated and that's in fact how reddit
ready got started so the hard part is
there's a great video by the way
on youtube if you want to see the how
reddit got started their fake until you
make it strategy where they had
20 or so accounts of different names and
they were posting every day on the
subreddit
like from 20 different personalities to
try to make it look like there was this
great
young community of interesting people
and then they described they were doing
that for like i don't know a couple
months or something and then
they described the day where they went
on it and just
it was all happening before they went
with their fake accounts like
the real people had built up enough
steam had learned like monkey sea monkey
do they learned how to behave here
and they were just posting the links and
commenting and it was like wait dude
that's not my account
this is a real account holy [__] this is
actually working and so
that's how they start it takes a lot of
time and reddit was is 10 years old so
when they were get i mean like the
amount of websites that existed versus
then
then versus now they had a lot less
competition it was still really hard
but what i found with this okay so
there's tech meme tech meme just
automatically pulls headlines based off
what's most shared on the internet
and then another example is let's run so
let's run.com the listener or the owner
of let's run.com
is actually a listen to our podcast and
i'm a big fan of fletcher.com
and it's basically the same thing people
submit articles and they comment on on
it
that's in the running niche yeah it's
like dorky runners long distance runners
very dorky
so so let me tell the story of product
hunt at the beginning how
how ryan did it right because i think
for a lot of these it's one thing to
hear
oh it's like i would agree with you
these social news sites social news
aggregators are amazing when they work
and they usually don't
okay so how do you get it to work well i
actually got to see ryan build
product kind of from the inside from day
one and if anybody doesn't know like
there's a funny article
basically ryan was interviewing to come
work at monkey inferno where i was the
ceo at the time
i was trying to recruit ryan because i
loved his blog post
and he was interviewing with us and he
got the final interview and didn't
didn't make it
um and i kept in touch with him i was
like hey you know sorry it didn't work
out but like
i'm still a big fan of yours and uh you
know
i want to give you the feedback why it
didn't work hope that's not salt in the
wound
but you know if i'm you i'd be curious
why did it why didn't i get it
and uh you know i really do want to keep
in touch and then the next week he was
like starting
product hunt literally i think one week
later he launched product hunt and uh
and i remember like you i was thinking
oh this is like cool but this is like
just some pet project it's not gonna go
anywhere why does he come work on the
real [__] and in reality product was
more successful than anything
we did in the lab so you know he won in
the end but i would say
what worked for him so he started it on
this thing called linky dick
uh which was like an off-the-shelf
little social news tool
i don't even think it's still around
it's not we started it there yeah it was
like an
email it was so weird it was like so the
way it worked was it was like hacker
news it was a list of
links but then it would send a recap to
all the subscribers of that board
like an email recap so even if you
forgot to go to the website
you'd get the wrap up automatically that
was kind of like a killer feature there
because
you're trying to build the habit of
people coming but they first like if you
could just deliver them value through
email
this will work um so i would say like
that was one like nice thing he did
he didn't need a tech he didn't need an
engineer at the beginning he used linky
being and linking the key was that they
would email the recap
then he only invited like friends that
he had developed that he knew were as
nerdy about products as he was so i
think i'm user number 15 or 17 of
product hunt
and it's because i was one of his nerdy
friends who really
like geeked out about new apps and new
products right that's what this podcast
kind of
right this word product or like now
you'll see people like oh i'm a product
guy
i'm almost that popular then i'm almost
positive people didn't really use that
word or phrase or if they did people
were like what are you talking about
well it was around like product manager
was obviously a phrase people talked
about products but it wasn't
as like it wasn't seen as like an anime
fan or a sports fan like it didn't seem
it wasn't like
a thing and he really said it a lot like
this is for people who geek out about
products that was his tagline
at the beginning and that's why you
should join this phrasing i knew what he
was talking about but i never heard
anyone say that and
and so he definitely kind of created a
little bit of a category
he made it cool i don't give him that i
think that he made it cool to do this
thing
so then he he curated the initial people
and they were cool people so it was like
because he had been blogging for four
years before that he had built up a
nice network in silicon valley so that
again that's the hard work that happened
before
that prepared him to succeed so then he
invites kevin rose he invites you know a
bunch of interesting people onto this
thing
and so people are sure and he he said i
set out to rule so just like i was
saying for crypto
hey this is for all crypto news except
price he said that for product
he's like this is for cool new products
don't post facebook and instagram like
we all know about that this is for the
[__] that you don't think the rest of
the group has seen yet
so that's where the real value came
that's what you would get here that was
different than
going to techcrunch or going to the app
store charts or whatever it's like
here you were going to dis discover the
new thing first
and uh not gonna see [__] that everybody
already knew about
so it kind of made it an insider like
it's set the level playing field of like
it's like if you were creating a wine
club
you would say like you know this is for
people who actually know about wines
don't bring you know
the seven dollar yellowtail you know
wine here
and so anyways i thought you got that
right then he made it where
you had to be whitelisted to participate
in the community meaning the average
person could not just go post so that
solved the bots problem and the
moderation problem
because he was only letting trusted
people post and anybody could view
and that that in this double effect of
it was now exclusive people wanted to
get in
they would beg to get in they would
prove themselves and if they got in they
would be on their best behavior so they
wouldn't get kicked out
and the last thing he did was he was
pretty maniacal about
curating the the community and the
products like every morning he would
wake up i don't know he's like kind of a
robot he like wakes up at 5am or 6am
every day like he's one of those guys
he's like
super productive yeah type of person and
um good habits you know
he would go to phil's coffee shop he
would sit down on his laptop and then he
would immediately
be scouring twitter anybody who
mentioned product he would thank them
anybody who posted a cool product he
would say hey i'd love for you to post
this on product time
he wouldn't do it he would tell them hey
this would be really cool if you post a
product now i just gave you access
and so that like built this habit and he
did that every goddamn day for like i
don't know nine months or something like
that before he hired
a community manager still probably
crushes i i use product hunt regularly i
don't actually know the numbers anymore
because i don't
i'm not sure but i bet you it's still
quite successful and it could
potentially be successful for 10 years
plus right if you've ever seen somebody
build a fire
without matches like i watch survivors
that's like i'm not a
i'm not a camper i don't know how it
works but on survivor this is like one
of the mainstays
is build a fire that's how i view
building a community like when you build
a fire on survivor it's like
first you're gonna like take the flint
and you like just gotta
you gotta shave the magnesium off the
flame boom boom boom boom
all right now you got enough of that and
now you're gonna like you know add the
next piece you're gonna like try to get
that to catch
and then as soon as it catches you gotta
very carefully don't let it like
extinguish it's so
like fragile at that time you gotta
start adding the little like brushwood
or whatever i don't know the words but
like
there's a certain type of thing you add
next then you add the sticks then you
build and now you have this raging
bonfire to me that's like what building
a community is like
i've seen the people who actually do
that that like really hard work of
shaving the flint first
and i'm like oh [__] that's what it
takes to do these like once these
communities are actually up and running
i've seen it once or twice now i've seen
you do it as well with trends
where you were posting every god damn
day in the trends group yeah for i don't
know how many months
that was your flint phase where you were
just shaving magnesium onto the water so
let me tell you about something that
we're launching
at the hustle i you guys can use it or
not i don't care i'm not
pimping it out right now uh but it's
related to this so what we're what we
are launching tomorrow on tuesday this
podcast on wednesday so it's actually
already live but i don't even know if
you're gonna be able to find it
yet but anyway it's called hustle plus
and what we're doing is we're kind of
launching something just like this
because i'm obsessed with these types of
products and i love these things and so
uh when a user signs up or they can
click out of the email once they're
already a subscriber
and they can tell us they can either
explicitly tell us
what they like or implicitly we can see
some of your behavior
and then we're gonna have a section of
headlines and in order to get those
headlines we built this tech that crawls
the internet and finds the most
shared stuff and shared headlines and
then let's say that you tell us or you
click on a bunch of articles related to
media and we've tagged all the links
like this is a media this is a media and
a
bootstrapping story whatever right uh
you're gonna get
those links in your email so you're
gonna get the hustle which is like
2 000 words of like editorial stuff but
you're gonna have one huge section with
10 or 20
just headlines then we're having we're
hiring a team of editors
to write a one sentence description of
that article
so it's part uh human part
machine telling you interesting stuff
right very
very similar to hacker news tech meme
things like that
um so that's actually we that's cool
yeah and so um
we're i'm doing that because i love
these types of things so it's basically
a hack
it's very similar to a hacker news not
so much user submitted right now but
kind of a similar idea
so i love these businesses and we've
talked about drudge report i think that
if you can get this to work it takes a
ton of work up front
very little work to maintain yes
yes exactly um okay so let's let's
switch topics let's do one of the other
ones
75. 75. okay so you've done a ton of
research about 75
75 hard i've had so many friends talk
about this
friends that mostly are not fit and this
has inspired them to get fit
uh okay so tell me about that part i i i
haven't heard anybody only ben has told
me about this oh my gosh
everyone is talking about this man so do
you remember um van trump report the
newsletter guy
i taught i told you about this guy who's
got this uh newsletter that crushes it
and
an ag tech i became friends with a son
his son lives in kansas city he's kind
of
talked to the southern accent he's not
like a techie uh he came over to my
house because he was visiting in texas
he's like hey i know you have a gym i'm
on my last workout i need to come use
your gym can i use it and then another
friend sujin patel
has been doing it and 75 hard has taken
over like my friends and they commit to
it like a religion like they don't
miss it right so describe what it is to
somebody and i
then i have a bunch of thoughts around
so 75 hard uh
i think what it means it's only got like
six rules it's basically you have to do
for 75 days two workouts a day
each workout needs to be 45 minutes one
workout needs to be outside
i don't think either workout needs to be
particularly hard the only rule is that
you have to sweat
uh the second rule is you have to have a
diet for all 75 days it doesn't matter
what diet you just have to do it
and that might be it is that the only
rule
i think that's it so so i had heard
about this uh ben told me about this a
little while ago
and then today he's like check out the
app charts and it's the number three
paid app in america right now
i said wow that's kind of amazing and so
i started looking into it and i actually
didn't do a ton of research on 75 hard
but i researched this category i'm very
interested in this category i finished
the story on 75 heart it started by this
guy andy i don't know his last name you
wrote it here i don't want to you know
okay everyone makes fun of me because i
can't say stuff he's actually based out
of right near me fenton missouri he has
a supplement company called
i think forma and it does about 200
million dollars in sales he was in my
local newspaper
because he um they like they bought a 20
million dollar building and invested it
and made it nice so i think they're
it's legit he's had several supplement
companies because i was like who is this
guy because if you see if you google
them it's like
it's one of those red flag type of
profiles like entrepreneur
speaker bestseller coach to celebrities
you know it's like oh [__]
you what have you done who are you it's
screaming not legit but he is legit
exactly and i i mean i can't [__] on it
too much like i'm a big tony robbins fan
and if you were to describe tony robbins
it'd be very very similar and like
but you kind of got to dig in be like i
definitely what i don't do is i don't
take that at face value
right cool so what are those businesses
okay great what is this book like you
know let me let me check this out let me
let me get a sense here so this guy's
got actually the top
one of the top podcasts in our category
in the business category
um it's called mf ceo or something like
that oh my gosh
um you know mother f and c or something
he's got a big instagram following so
who is this guy
from what i know which i just did a very
quick dive
actually i'd love to have this guy on
the pod um he
he basically he's uh he started a couple
supplement companies i think first was
like a brick and mortar
supplement company called something
supplements super supplements or
something like that
and he's got he's done that two or three
times his third one is called form one
and that's i think the biggest one it's
been the most successful
and you know the hook or the tagline is
like you know these
brands do over 100 million dollars a
year so okay he's in the supplement
space
he did well with that great and then he
like translated that into like a life
philosophy and i think he preaches kind
of he's like a
bit of the jocko willing like kind of
school of thought which is just like
you know it's hard man you gotta work
hard yeah man up
do it grind uh hustle blah blah those
are the words right so he's like gary v
if garyvee was like jacked you know and
so he's like you know in that that fame
that's the outsider i haven't got i have
not drank the kool-aid of what his
stuff is that's my outsider quick point
of view okay great
but i started thinking about this by the
way i just wanna i'm gonna cover your
ass here
sean sounded and sort of died a little
dismissive of this guy i
yeah i don't think you are trying to
sound that way and neither am i i think
this guy
seems like a good dude i view it very
much
in the like i can have two thoughts at
the same time
one thought is oh when i hear this stuff
it's usually a bit of hand wavy and
usually these people are kind of like
stereotype
kind of caricatures um but also
they're probably like actually giving
out good information inspiring a lot of
people
have had great success in their life and
live up to a lot of these things and
like i think both of those are kind of
true like
i kind of make fun of gary vee but i
think gary v has built like kind of an
awesome brand and an awesome
company and he's an awesome guy like you
know like i don't know personally but
i can simultaneously make fun of the
character while also being like you know
respect you did your thing
like you did the thing you want to do
and that's not easy most people do
nothing so
you know props props for not not just
doing nothing but doing something very
unique
so so this space so i'm very interested
in this
um for kind of a reason i've actually
considered launching something like this
so that's why i looked into it
uh so 75 i'm very interested in these
time-bounded
challenges time-bounded programs so the
big one that i personally had experience
with was p90x
so i don't know if you did you ever do
p90x of course
tony what was his name what was the guy
named tony horton tony horton of course
okay so here's the kind of back story of
p90x i think it's interesting
there's this company called beachbody
and what beachbody did was
it was started by this guy carl deichler
i would consider him our billy of the
week
so he's a ceo he's worth about 600
million dollars
and this guy is kind of the king of
infomercials and the king of
of us of sort of at home fitness so
he created eight-minute abs um
you know he he created eight-minute abs
which is like he was inspired by buns of
steel
he like loved this like branding of a
fitness program
and he he was pretty early and jumped on
in the kind of early 90s this time
really started hammering infomercials on
tv that was his main channel like today
facebook ads is i think the infomercials
of today but he was really the master of
infomercials back
then and so he's like all right i'm
gonna do i'm gonna create this company
and
originally he wanted to call it i think
like um
he so he's like i want to start this
company he goes to his friends and
family he raises 500
dollars from angel uh angel investor
friends and family
he says all right i'm gonna test five
products and i'm gonna see what sticks
and they're gonna be in this like
fitness space
and the whole idea was like i have this
distribution channel
infomercials and i'm gonna create
products that are sticky that people
that help people
lose weight essentially get more fit and
so he starts with the very first one i
think was
tony he goes to tony horton tony horton
at the time is a celebrity trainer
so he's training bruce springsteen and
like all these kind of like musicians
and actors and actresses in hollywood
so he goes to tony and he says let's
create a product called
great body guaranteed and he's like oh i
love it great body guaranteed
how can it miss and he goes to he tries
to get greatbody.com and it's taken
and so he's like doing his thing he's
walking around on the beach in l.a
walking home one day and he's like
he's on the beach he just thinks
beachbody beachbody.com he runs home
checks out
checks beachbody.com is available so he
grabs it
and so he starts trying to produce these
infomercials with tony for this program
and they've produced many many programs
um and and he
realized at the time okay like i can't
afford celebrity endorsements right like
that's why tony had a good name was
because he was training for celebrities
but
he couldn't really afford celebrity
endorsements so they start just trying
to do like
um like kind of like uh infomercials
without that so customer testimonials so
he comes up with this idea that the
customer is the celebrity
how do i make the customer a celebrity
anyway so what he the initial
batch of infomercial title actually
failed where he was just saying
you know get a great body and it's just
super jacked people
on screen saying how jacked they are
basically and so instead
you know it's kind of just money down
the drain during that part and instead
they try one version of the infomercial
where they took
a few testimonials that had been sent in
from their buyers that said hey look at
you know this was me before
and this is me now and me now wasn't
like
didn't look like a greek god but just
like definitely looked better than the
out of shape overweight person you know
in the before photo
so they slap those into the infomercial
like real customer testimonials
and boom this thing starts selling like
hotcakes and so
he realizes oh wait the more authentic
these look and so he started
curating he goes i want the customer
testimonials to almost look like
america's funniest home video footage
like somebody at home their cats jumping
on them while they're doing a sit-up
their plant is you know dying in the
background they can barely hold their
balance while doing the pose
and then you see the after photo 90 days
later that they look great
and that was his kind of core insight
that was working really really well
and he was very differentiated because
everybody else was who was doing
at home was really at this time was
doing like
some gimmick product like thigh master
ab roller bowflex like selling some
equipment
this equipment will solve your problems
and it said he was like no no
i'm gonna make a promise you do my
program for 90 days you get this result
and that promise marketing was much
better and that's what 75 heart is too
it's another variant of this promise
marketing well there's a tight
difference i think
so if i i don't know i don't think it's
like this anymore but when 75 hard first
started
it was around as a free movement so
basically this guy
would say like all right everyone it's
that time of year we're doing it
and he would it's like no shave november
yeah i forget the months
but i've i've seen i've seen it for a
couple years now and he would basically
i guess
instagram like now's the time for the
challenge and i think he did it for like
maybe four years before it even became a
thing so p90x i think
it's a you enroll and you have 90 days
to get it done this
75 hard thing was a you know november
first
get ready like you know time to get rid
of seasonal things yeah and it worked
really well i guess is 75 hard now like
a rolling 75
i i think it's i i think so because they
have this app so i don't think it's just
one time of the year
but um and if it's number three right
now and we're in
june or we're in april so i think you
know it's it's definitely not the
november thing as it was before
and so just to go back to beachbody so
beachbody the company does over a
billion dollars a year in revenue just
to break down their business
they basically so he he comes up with
this concept of that of
uh gym at home instead of a home gym so
it's like how do you do the gym workout
at home
and uh he's like okay we have we're
gonna use infomercials and we're going
to use dvds dvds are going to be great
because you're going to be able to put
it on your tv
and you do it whenever you want sort of
on demand great
and so you start selling dvds and the
dvds do well and
programs like p90x are part of it and
for p90x it was actually a little bit of
a pivot
for them there's actually these cool
videos on youtube of them in their
meetings
and he's pitching this he's like okay
look right now we're all about losing
weight
it's all weight loss it's all um uh like
kind of like belly fat
that's the market we go after for
beachbody but for p90x i want to do
something different
he's like we need like an extreme
program for the muscle builder he's like
i noticed
there's all these magazines like men's
fitness and muscle muscle monthly
and all this stuff where people are
really trying to like build huge muscles
and so let's set out the tenants for
this thing and he's like doing a
presentation he's like
this is not for beginners this is at
home this is meant to build muscles get
shredded
you're going to get shredded in 90 days
he's like that's the promise we're going
to make to the people
and so he you know i like seeing these
meetings where people are like
coming up with the the concept that they
know you know takes over the nation type
of thing
and so their model is you have the dvds
and then he's like okay cool
distribution through infomercials was
good
but we've kind of hit our limit there so
then he took a page out of the amway
mlm playbook he's like here's what we'll
do we'll get our
our most successful customers will
become our coaches we'll teach
them how to sell this program for
themselves how to be their own mini tony
horton
so they go and they build this
nationwide network of 400 000
coaches and then of course the coaches
can train other coaches and they can
keep a share of their revenue right
classic mlm multi-level marketing some
people call it a pyramid scheme or a
ponzi scheme but there's a there's a
legal way to do this and he's doing it
the legal way
and so the top coaches i think in his
case it's an
i'm reading all about him it's an mln
but it's not i don't
find this to be unethical or bad i mean
it's just he's he's making customer
sales people for him
so i was once talking to a friend and he
was like dude we need to create
this product and we'll do it we'll sell
it as mlm i was like dude mlm isn't that
like
you know isn't that like a sin he's like
why he's like it's basically
you get your your hardcore believers do
i know this arm them with the ability to
sell it
you know the friend yeah i think i i
think i know and i think they love
mlms because an mlm almost bought them
um
yeah and mlms inherently are not wrong
now exactly the way he described it he
goes look there's a knob
think about this way this is a model
just like affiliate marketing or any
kind of viral marketing
um you basically give people products
and let them sell it um
it's like there's a knob though the knob
is like kind of like your evil knob
and you could turn it down to zero and
when you're at zero you're basically
saying hey
if you're a fan of our product you can
become one of our coaches
and um you can there's no minimums you
don't have to subscribe to this monthly
thing
you don't have to like uh you know do
this the wrong way is like or you turn
it up to 12 and you go super evil and
you basically say
hey dude you could become a millionaire
if you become one of our coaches
look at this guy he's a millionaire
don't you want to be a millionaire and
then you basically get them to sign up
for this thing where they have to pay
you 100
a month they have to buy ten thousand
dollars of product and now they're
they're their kids bedroom is full of
like this this you know
hair loss uh you know shampoo treatment
that they need to sell and then they
can't sell but they bought ten thousand
dollars worth and you made your money
anyways
and then they go broke because they try
to become one of your reps and like you
you that knob is like in your control to
turn how screwed up you want to be with
it
and so anyways i think beachbody is like
somewhere in the not so evil category
from what i know
uh their top tr their cup coaches and
trainers make about like
two to three million dollars a year um
and a lot of that revenue again comes
from the coaches that they brought on
board
um they get a percentage of their sales
and the company by the way beachbody i'm
reading all about
um their ceo and he's giving an
interview and he says they do
this year and 20 they'll do a billion in
sales and they do about 10 percent
ebitda
so a hundred million in net profit
uh on a billion in sales
yeah i'm surprised it's not better the
way that they
describe their mod of ads the way they
describe their model is like
they have the dvds which now has become
streaming they have the coaches to go
like distribute those
like that's their sales their sales
force and they make all their profit on
the shakes
so the whole thing comes down to this
like shake product they have called
shakeology
and basically it's like okay the the
streaming or the dvds the content
that's good but it's not like it costs
so much to market it it's not that good
um okay you know the coaches well you
got to recruit them you got to train
them they got to sell
they're good but they're not that good
the shakes it's like 130 dollars for
your one month of nutrition shakes
um and that's like pure margin it goes
back to that andy facility guys like
supplement company
it's like they make all their money the
profits come from the shakes
and the whole thing with the coaches is
like cool we get you hooked on this
program and then you want better results
feel better results you got to trim up
that diet hey here's what i do i drink
these delicious shakes
they're so tasty and they are
i did not know that yeah so that's
that's their model so i think
beachbody is a pretty fascinating
company i think that these
i think that marketing your product as a
x days promise is a very smart idea
because you're basically saying you're
going to get this result
in this much time whether that's eight
minute abs or
p90x or 75 hard or it's that diet whole
30 where you're gonna do 30 days of
eating whole foods only
like i've seen this work so many times
i'm very fascinated by it i don't know
why it works in the psychology
of the of the customer but it definitely
does work
and then the last piece is i think one
of the reasons it works is because
customers can sort of commit to like
well i can do this for x days that
doesn't sound too hard 90 days i could
do anything for 90 days
30 day diet okay like maybe i'm not
going to change my diet and become a
vegan
but can i eat whole foods for 30 days
all right that's a challenge and i
thought it was very interesting the way
he talked about this which was
there's two ways to market it because
we've always marketed our products as
you can do it like this is so easy you
can do it
and what 75 heart of p90x do is the
opposite they go
can you do it it's a challenge to you
like i don't know if you can do it this
is it's hard
right so then they started creating all
these pro they have two versions of
their marketing
you can do it marketing and can you do
it marketing and i love that i thought
that was such an interesting way of like
thinking about your business they have a
program called insanity
why is it called insanity because it's
meant to sound super [__] hard and
too crazy
and like why is p90x it's the extreme
home workout
it's not that easy beginner sit-ups and
push-up stuff this is the extreme so i
thought that was pretty cool
okay so what we're going to launch in
this space so i've been working with my
trainer now
and i'm actually like i've hit some
tipping point where i'm starting to get
results like i look at my body
like during the during our sessions and
like we work out in my garage
there's this one area where the sun like
comes into my garage
and the shadow is just perfect and i
look [__] great and i'm like dude
this i need to stay in here like can we
do my center it works with exercising
it's like
no results no results no results boom it
all kind of ha it feels like it happens
dude that's how everything valuable was
like
slowly slowly slowly then suddenly um
and so it's like all business success
works that way and i'm now saying even
fitness success works that way where
there is a tipping point
and where now the workouts i don't dread
them i enjoy them i'm looking forward to
them i feel bad if i ever
get miss a day whereas before i was like
sweet snow day don't have to work out
you know like
i was looking forward to missing it now
now i'm looking forward to doing it
so anyways i was talking to my trainer
and i was like dude
i'm gonna help you i'm gonna help you
create because he's always hearing me
talk about business and it's like he's
a black belt in fitness i like to
consider myself like really good at uh
business and we're trying to help each
other out and so i told him i was like
dude why don't you do this like why
don't you create
like he's a gem to me he's not like a
normal trainer he's like
i've told many stories about how he
helps my mindset and all this stuff and
he's really talking
too i'm like dude you're cut above like
most people i was like we should create
one of these where it's like
i was like just with my friends like
just the people i know in my my
my life who if i post a photo of me
today and i post a
photo of me like a few months ago before
i started working out with you
like i'm gonna post that before and
after photo that's my own pride moment
of like i did it i actually turned the
corner of this thing that's been
forever a really hard thing for me i've
never really considered myself
fit or shredded or like been proud to
take off my shirt but i think i'm going
to get there pretty soon like
within a few months i think i'm going to
get there i was like when i post that
after photo i was like we should open up
something that says
if you want to do it like let's create
our own 90-day program and like let
people in because i was like
the way i was thinking about it was he
has this philosophy which is like
um we talked about like um how do you
feel when your friends get successful
and um and i told him honestly i was
like yeah like it's been hard for me
like
when my friend when sam sells this
company pretended all of a sudden sam's
got tens of millions of dollars that's
like
i'm happy for you yes i'm not like not
happy for you but there's a bigger part
of me in that moment right when the news
hits that's like
oh [__] i'm behind right you know i was
like the honest truth was like
i get kind of jealous or like i'm
getting kind of envious and so he helped
me sort of
reframe that in my mind this is not
about you but like it's been this way
for decades you know like
i always felt this way if somebody's
successful like good for them but bad
for me
and he's like you know it doesn't have
to be that way good for them bad for me
it can be good for them it's good for me
he's like it's just this philosophy you
got to have where do you carry yourself
where you say
it's not just that i'm going to win i'm
going to help bring up all the people
around me we're all going to win
and it's going to be more fun that we're
all going to win he's like you do this
with investing right
you share your deals and you co-invest
and you let your you want your friends
to invest in your companies
because when you win it's more fun to
toast together and drink together he's
like
same thing with like all aspects of life
you should be thinking about
i'm not just gonna win i'm gonna win so
much there's gonna be so much like
success around me
that all the people around me are gonna
be successful too anyways
long story short of i heard him tell me
about that and i
i took it to him i go i'm gonna help you
build a business
that does this i'm gonna take the thing
you're really good at that you're doing
for me and now i have him working with
my sister my mom
my sister's kids uh my sister-in-law i
paid you know like
we do all of their fitness now through
him he's like my family's personal coach
really and so i'm like yeah he's doing
that's i'm we're his only clients
anymore
it's just like my own family what uh can
you like
tell me what you pay this person uh no i
don't want to put him on blast like that
you want to talk about his name you want
to say his name or do you want to even
hide him
yeah i mean i call him j.a that's his
name is john alexander so he goes short
for j.a and he's not being on social
media or nothing like that like he
doesn't
try to be like some influencer guy or
whatever a trainer
yeah he's a trainer that's what he's
been doing he's been you know fit his
whole life and you know he's really good
at that
a shaved head white guy no i don't know
i'll send you his instagram later
um but basically i want to
i want to help him be successful i think
we can use one of these like
i think we can use this model of this
p90x or 75 hard
let people commit to something that's
reasonable for them that's the way i did
it with him i was like
all right i'm gonna i'm gonna commit i
don't know how good you are how bad i am
i don't know if
i can do this long term but like i'll
comment i'll give you 30 days to get my
ass off this couch like i'm just
i'm sick of this get my ass going 30
days i will do anything you [__] say
one hour a day i will sweat my ass off
and like that got me hooked
and so i think we're going to come up
with some program like that this is
we're like months away from actually
launching something but i want to do
that because i think a
i want to share him with more people and
b i just think this is a cool business
model
why do you do everything you do why like
why do you not focus more on one or two
things and i criticize you i don't
criticize you
i i i challenge you often
why continually why do this do that do
that do this
why not just do one thing and crush it
because
and your your answer i might be well
because i just want to explore to see
everything out there
but it's pretty obvious what you're good
at
which is what i have a feeling that your
rolling fund is going to be wildly
successful
uh i have a feeling that like
you pull a lot of the weight in the
podcast because you're you're very good
at content
why do everything instead of just be the
best at this you're this
in this little lane i do think about
that
um i think i've graduated out of being
an operator
i no longer want to operate one entity
the only nc i want to operate
is uh you know seanco my life
and when i think about like what would
be the most exciting version of that how
do i
how do i marry this part of me that's
just
super curious and every day you know i
want to go down the rabbit hole
and learn how 75 hard works and not you
know p90x works right
before this podcast i would do that
anyways i just didn't have an excuse i
didn't have an outlet i would just do
the research
shove it in my head and then i would go
about my job in my life and i would keep
running my company which had nothing to
do with fitness right this podcast was a
cool thing because it gave me an excuse
to do more of that thing i'm interested
in i do good at and now it's a win-win
now i go down those rabbit holes i learn
those things
i come here i share the learnings and
cool we
we get which uh we're both doing which
is
and then you like oh i think this is
actually a really good idea let's go put
money again and then i see the company
and then i basically say cool now i'm
going to invest my money
i'm going to share my knowledge to an
operator who can go
start that business and so my training
this will be my trainer's business it's
not gonna be my business
but i will plant the seed with them that
hey this would be great and i'll do
everything in my power to help you be
successful meaning i'll give you seed
funding
i'll be your test customer testimonial
like that's that's on me to get
get make my after picture better than my
before picture
and then lastly like i'll [__] i'll
spread the love i'll spread the word
about about your thing when
the time comes whenever you're ready
like i wasn't planning on talking about
it today it's just
coinciding with let's talk about
beachbody so anyways i would say like
that to me is a more fun life i
basically decided all right i want my
life to be
where i wake up and whatever i'm most
curious about i go do
because i have a way to monetize my own
curiosity i have a way to monetize my
own learnings
okay so how do i that's what i've
decided is my thing for the next decade
i'm going to push
a little bit because i actually think
that that your premise might be a little
flawed here which is i'm going to wake
up and i'm going to do
what i want i'm going to no no i'm going
to go
learn about what i'm most interested in
what i'm most curious about
and i would actually actually i would
challenge that a little bit because it's
like
well you're kind of implying that you're
each day you're going to do a new thing
and i don't necessarily like like for
crypto like i've spent months
in crypto right because you know years
of curiosity but then like months of
pretty hardcore curiosity
around that i think that's good and it's
become like a bigger part of my
portfolio of time and money
and so say you know same thing with
e-commerce i got more interested in
e-commerce right
same thing with live streaming for many
years it was all about live streaming so
these don't have to be every day it's a
new topic i think that would be a bit
extreme
but um but with the podcast yeah you
know we do two of these a week
we talk about three different topics
each time we're by no means experts at
any of those it's like very
kind of like off the cuff type of
conversation and research
but i think it's like the way i think
about it is like
tim ferriss has done this if i've seen
anybody do it i think that tim ferriss
has done this where he's uh
he's very curious about certain things
that he wants to go learn so then he
goes talks to people in that space
he does experiments on himself he reads
books about that topic he reads research
papers about the topic
and then he packages it up into
something that's sellable sometimes and
sometimes it's not sellable and it's
just for him it's just for his own
curiosity
i think i could do that i think i can
create the new new business model of
being tim ferriss
so that would be if what's my one thing
i think it's that but to the outside it
looks like
a lot of variety and to me that's good
it's
but it's well i'm not trying to
criticize it here i'm just trying to
bring in a different perspective
um because i was thinking about i
i saw i know this guy who's like getting
something off the ground and i see him
constantly talking about like
side projects day trading um
um bitcoin yadda yadda yadda and this
business is really
related to something totally separate
i'm like what are you doing dude just
like
right lock yourself in the room don't do
anything except for like
be with your family exercise and like
work on your thing
um right because like it seems almost
not not impossible some are really good
at it but
for most it seems almost impossible to
create anything meaningful
without a maniacal amount of focus at
least early on for an extended period of
time more likely than not though
um i think that's true i think that's
true and it's it would be definitely
true if i said oh i'm gonna go start a
company
i'm gonna raise much money and this is
gonna be uh i'm gonna make this huge
company
i'm not doing that that's not my thing
right now so like if when i was doing
that
i didn't have a podcast i didn't have a
fund i didn't have a blog
i didn't have i didn't have a girlfriend
i didn't have many things i sacrificed
on many of those
because i was all in sleeping at the
office 200 days here
i just know that that's not what this
next phase looks like for me
i could do that again i don't really
want to and so i'm trying to see
is there a better model for me that that
is more of that feels effortless to me
that always felt like a lot of effort
and i think that there is a version of
life that it doesn't have to be so hard
uh i think it can be speedy and easy i
think it can be effortless
if you're doing the thing you really
enjoy doing i agree with that on a
day-to-day basis i wouldn't use the word
effortless but it's uh
it's it's uh rewarding like when you
play
do you feel like you're working hard no
like i can go play basketball i could be
really tired by the end of it so i mean
fatigue because i've played basketball
for three hours
but at no point in it would i feel like
i'm having to like
do something i don't want to be doing oh
my god i mean if you want to use that
play thing like i don't always i love to
exercise but i don't always want to go
do it but i'm always happy that i did do
it
uh and like uh i don't want to because
to me working out
is not like play play is a really
specific word
uh play is like you know i could be
tired from my job i'll come home i can
play video games
and video games take actually like you
know focus hand-eye coordination
strategy talking to your teammates all
that stuff
but because it's fun it doesn't feel
like work to me right and so
i'm interested in in play now i'm not
interested in hard work
so um where do we go from here uh i
think we might wrap it as there's been a
little
we went on kind of tangents there
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be
what i want to i put my all in it like
no days off
on a roll let's travel never looking
back